[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrados
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 verán esta semana mezclamos la
situación sanitaria con la geopolítica
para hablar de un tema muy muy muy
interesante el juego diplomático de las
vacunas para ello me acompañan en este
estudio françois villon editor del medio
internacional en el medio media par
bienvenido françois buenos días david
gormezano periodista compañero de france
24 especialista en latinoamérica
bienvenido david buenos días carlos y en
dúplex desde moscú nuestro corresponsal
xavier con las sabias buenos días hola
un saludo a todos y encantado de estar
otra vez por aquí con vosotros la
diplomacia y la geopolítica de las
vacunas hoy en primera plana
[Música]
las tan esperadas vacunas contra el
coronavirus se han convertido en el
campo de batalla diplomática entre las
grandes potencias mundiales con rusia y
china- la cabeza sin olvidar por
supuesto india y con europa y eeuu en un
segundo plano para potencias como china
rusia o india la carta del prestigio se
juega en los países más pobres donde se
han impuesto con los proveedores de este
escaso bien mientras las potencias de
occidente sumergidas en una nueva ola de
la pandemia reservan las dosis de las
vacunas para su población de todo ello
vamos a hablar hoy en primera plana
antes vamos a este juego diplomático en
plena crisis sanitaria antes vamos a
repasar algunas portadas que lo ilustran
de spectator' la guerra de las vacunas
muy ilustrativa está esta portada del
tema que hoy vamos a abordar aquí en
francia el diario libération hace uno de
sus juegos de palabras habituales con
los problemas que está teniendo la umh
europea con la vacuna de astrazéneca y
titula
atracaba dantesco un nuevo calificativo
que a partir de ahora quizás podamos
utilizar también en eeuu en new york
times' el juego diplomatique diplomático
por las vacunas contra la cob y 19 india
china y emiratos árabes unidos y otros
países reparten donaciones en las
regiones donde buscan tener influencia
bueno françois la vacuna contra el
coronavirus uno de los productos más
demandados en estos momentos del mundo
no sé si podremos decir que se ha
convertido en el gran elemento en el
elemento pilar ahora mismo del juego
diplomático mundial sí sí sí por
supuesto como lo ha dicho ese ocurre en
un momento especial cuando grandes
potencias como china por ejemplo se
puede como una potencia mundial que
puede competir con eeuu entonces ocurre
en ese momento peculiar en el mundo y
podemos ver que es una guerra de vacunas
también con este intereses geopolíticos
pero también intereses económicos y
también con consideración sanitaria
david que pretende en países como china
india o rusia a través de esta
diplomacia de vacunas bueno en el caso
de américa latina por ahora solamente 4%
de las vacunas a nivel mundial han
llegado a américa latina entonces es
difícil para los países de américa
latina conseguirlas transgénica five-0
moderna y demás de forma natural
los dos vacunas de china y el sputnik de
rusia más baratas también más económicas
para países de la región
han encontrado a gobiernos que están a
la búsqueda de vacunar su población y
han ofrecido sus productos en cantidad
por ahora no muy importante pero por
ejemplo el caso de argentina el país
vive a la expectativa de las llegadas de
vuelos desde moscú que traen vacunas a
todos los canales de televisión están
ahí del aeropuerto diciendo hoy ha
llegado a 300 300 mil dosis de la vacuna
sputnik
y con mucha polémica que pone el país
con la estrategia de parte de china
ya lo sé pero demanda de los países de
américa latina por vacunas piden de
india vienen de china vienen de rusia
hay una expectativa tremenda en los
países pues vamos a irnos precisamente a
rusia con nuestra corresponsables de
xavier colás porque los occidentales
perciben no sé cómo decirlo con un poco
de recelo la diplomacia de rusia basada
en la vacuna anti kobe pese a que ya
parezca haber convencido a los expertos
independientes en febrero la revista
científica the lancet confirmó su
eficacia en salir como se defiende moscú
de este llamado oportunismo diplomático
el moscú siempre se ha agarrado
este halo que publicó en su momento la
revista the lancet para defender que su
vacuna es segura desde rusia están muy
interesados en tener algún tipo de
presencia en la unión europea no solo
como cliente sino también como productor
de las vacunas rusia lo que critica es
que existe una especie de cliché
respecto a rusia y que se le está
pidiendo la vacuna es pública algunas
garantías que niñas se le están
solicitando a algunas otras vacunas como
por ejemplo la facer o la de astra
zéneca moscú en lo que insiste es que no
se trata de un criterio científico lo
que está frenando la llegada de la
vacuna sputnik a la unión europea sino
de razones políticas y por eso pide que
la salud y la seguridad y el bienestar
de los europeos es más que otro tipo de
enfrentamientos clichés o rencores
respecto a rusia en el pasado así que
podemos decir que ahora moscú a bandera
el punto de vista científico en contra
de la pelea geopolítica si quizá david a
propósito de lo que nos está contando
nuestro corresponsal quizá en
latinoamérica pesan menos pesen menos
esos clichés hacia rusia y asia lo que
supone la vacuna que en los países
europeos es lo que estamos viendo la
actualidad no seguramente porque rusia
como china son socios económicos de
países de latinoamérica desde al menos
dos décadas china es un comprador de
materia prima muy importante para los
países de américa latina desde hace
décadas
y rusia también es un socio de muchos
países de latinoamérica en el ámbito de
la energía y por ejemplo de la energía
nuclear hay hay convenios firmados con
argentina con con bolivia por con el
sector
nuclear así que
o rusia y china no son desconocidos no
no no nos llegan así de la nada en
américa américa latina
y tienen vínculos con con países como
venezuela como cuba con un aspecto muy
político pero en otros países en perú en
chile en argentina en brasil
china y rusia están en el paisaje desde
muchos años los países que disponen de
los medios utilizan las vacunas para
ganarse el favor de sus aliados o para
descongelar sus relaciones y no nos a
asia india las envió a nepal un país en
el que china tiene cada vez más
influencia sur y la ncaa que está en
medio de negociaciones diplomáticas con
nueva delhi pekín por el momento recibe
dosis de ambos pero en de china que
están fabricando vacunas para el resto
del mundo tienen grandes poblaciones que
necesitan inocular preguntó françois no
tiene grandes riesgos esta estrategia de
usar la vacuna como elemento de
influencia sin tener vacuna da tu propia
población si bueno tiene ese problema de
que china por ejemplo exporta mucho
ahora pero va a tener un problema con su
propia población para vacunar bueno para
tener vacunas para vacunar los entonces
si es un juego un poco complicado
y si lo tiene que tomar en cuenta yo
creo pero bueno para para china es es
algo muy interesante porque porque china
yo creo que la diferencia con rusia
rusia no tiene capacidad así que bueno
de producción de sus vacunas es su
estrategia es intentar encontrar países
donde se pueden producir el sputnik
china tiene capacidad es hay una como
intereses económicos y es ante todo para
hablar desde de esta guerra de las
vacunas es un mercado y china puede
puede éste suplir a la gente a los
países que necesiten como dice david
esas vacunas porque cuáles son los
cuatro los elementos para para para una
vacuna es
el precio la capacidad de detener de
conseguirla rápidamente la seguridad y
la eficiencia entonces esos cuatro
elementos son muy importantes para un
país y china por ejemplo a veces
consigue esos cuatros elementos por
ejemplo en chile fue uno de los países
donde donde pudo dar a chile vender a
chile vacunas antes que los mayores
productores de vacunas que son los
occidentales si lo que se está tomando
como ejemplo de campaña de éxito junto a
israel no
si chile tiene está muy exitoso en su
campaña de la ovulación
la tasa de contaminación está todavía
muy elevada en chile- así que los
resultados no sé no se ven muy muy
claramente ahora pero si le está
siguiendo un camino hizo tiene tiene una
tradición de negociación con empresas
privadas en el sector farmacéutico que
le permitió avanzar rápidamente
ahora brasil que es el gigante de
latinoamérica de latinoamérica
tiene una postura
entre la toda la vacunar y producir
vacunas que está muy raro y con un país
tan grande que tiene un problema de
contaminación tan elevado es un problema
también para los otros países es un
riesgo un peligro para los niños así que
hay cada país tiene sus opciones y su
política para conseguir algunas pero la
el tamaño de la de la pandemia en el
continente debe ser controlada eso es un
es un parámetro fundamental ahora vamos
a volver a moscú como sabía colas
esperamos que obtener una ventaja
gracias a la presión que se está
produciendo ahora mismo en europa en un
aumento de contagios y a la desunión
respecto algunos socios del bloque que
negocian con moscú de forma unilateral
como por ejemplo austria o hungría ha
recibido ya ha conseguido alguna ventaja
con esa desunión y es que por lo menos
empieza el debate ha empezado ya hace
tiempo y no sólo se trata de que algunos
socios comunitarios como por ejemplo
y eslovaquia ya estén comprando vacunas
rusas por su cuenta sin esperar al visto
bueno de la ema es que también hay
algunos líderes europeos que ya han
dicho que por qué no usar la vacuna rusa
en un futuro sobre todo si reciben la
luz verde del principal regulador
existen algunos análisis que apuntan a
que rusia siempre está interesada en que
haya algún tipo de desunión
política dentro del seno de la unión
europea aunque sólo sea porque moscú
siempre ha preferido una unión europea
con menos contenido político una digamos
unión de fronteras pero un moscú siempre
ha preferido las relaciones bilaterales
país a país no con la unión europea como
conjunto que muchas veces es vista en
moscú como una avanzadilla de la otan y
por lo tanto una avanzadilla de eeuu así
que ya ha sido un primer paso para moscú
el que exista al menos ese debate y
además bueno desde instancias europeas
incluso se ha mostrado mi interés por la
vacuna rusa uno de los problemas es que
rusia desde el principio me transfirió
todos los datos que tenía sobre su
vacuna y luego a la hora de solicitar
formalmente el poder entrar en ese
circuito de vacunas europeos tampoco lo
hizo en tiempo y forma a pesar del
discurso oficial del gobierno ruso ahora
se pueden intentar apurar plazos y
correr pero va a ser una cuestión en la
de la vacuna rusa que no se va a
solucionar ni muchísimo menos en 24
horas
bueno en seguida les quiero preguntar
por este debate que se ha creado en
europa hacemos una breve pausa y
continuamos hablando de la diplomacia de
las vacunas en primera plana
[Música]
i
años después de su creación el mercosur
pasa por horas bajas debido a la
posición y solo accionista del
presidente jair bolsonaro este acuerdo
ya tuvo efectos positivos en brasil
permitió la libre circulación de
personas y aumentó la estabilidad
disipando la histórica desconfianza
entre brasil y argentina sin embargo
ahora tanto el mercosur como los brics
pasan por un momento de hibernación
según dicen fuentes diplomáticas debido
precisamente a la postura política de
bolsonaro ya las diferencias ideológicas
que él mantiene con el actual gobierno
de argentina además una parte importante
de ese acuerdo que es el acuerdo entre
la unión europea y el mercosur también
está bloqueado debido a la política
medioambiental de brasilea un aumento de
los índices de deforestación hay que
recordar que el mercosur reúne a más de
295 millones de personas es la quinta
economía del mundo y el año pasado en
plena pandemia realiza unas
exportaciones por el valor de 250 mil
de dólares su futuro es incierto porque
bolsonaro es imprevisible
[Música]
con argentina en la presidencia
protémpore del mercosur
cumple 30 años en un contexto de crisis
por la pandemia pero también por
cuestiones internas del bloque nació con
la idea de avanzar hacia un mercado
común y potenciar las economías de sus
miembros o un primer impulso hacia esos
objetivos y en lo social se mejoró la
movilidad de las personas entre países
del bloque con facilidades para residir
y trabajar hoy en argentina sin embargo
muchos ven al mercosur como un ancla 1
porque consideran la competencia de los
productos brasileños el más poderoso
miembro del bloque como una amenaza y
otros porque entienden que el mercosur
debe abrirse más al mundo y reducir
barreras al comercio aunque por ahora
están estancados importantes acuerdos de
libre comercio con otros países
especialmente con la unión europea en
todo caso a pesar de las críticas y en
el marco de una creciente centralidad de
china en los intercambios globales el
mercosur y especialmente brasil siguen
siendo el principal socio comercial de
argentina
[Música]
a 30 años del tratado de asunción que
dio inicio el mercosur el bloque
regional es visto por distintos sectores
paraguayos con más sombras que luces uno
de esos sectores es el de los
empresarios que históricamente tuvo
obstáculos para vender sus productos en
argentina-brasil a pesar de los acuerdos
arancelarios las asimétricas economías
de cada país se siguen imponiendo hoy el
gobierno de paraguay se suma al reclamo
de uruguay y brasil de una mayor
flexibilización que permita a cada país
realizar de forma independiente acuerdos
bilaterales esta idea sin embargo es
vista con mucha cautela en paraguay
donde el 64 por ciento de las
exportaciones en 2020 fueron al mercosur
en el ámbito político la sanción
impuesta al país por el bloque en 2012
tras la destitución de fernando lugo aún
causa mucha irritación en aquellos
sectores que impulsaron el juicio
político visto en su momento por el
mercosur como un golpe parlamentario
finalmente la incapacidad de una compra
conjunta entre los países del bloque de
vacunas contra el coronavirus desató aún
más críticas en paraguay debido a que el
país hoy se encuentra con uno de los
peores registros de vacunación contra el
cob y 19 en todo
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando del juego diplomático con las
vacunas en plena pandemia lo hacemos con
françois villon bullón editor
internacional de mediapart david
gormezano periodista de france 24 y
desde moscú nuestro corresponsal
xavier colás no está contando sabía cómo
rusia intenta aprovechar este momento de
debate en la unión europea respecto a la
conveniencia de la vacuna sputnik y nos
apunta antes david pues como a lo mejor
desde latinoamérica y menos clichés
asociados a esa vacuna que era mejor
también han contaminado un poco el
debate aquí en europa les pregunto qué
les parece esta posición además de
desunión de la unión europea respecto a
la línea adoptar respecto a la vacuna
rusa con algunos países por cierto
negociando por su cuenta
hanson bueno primero lo que voy a decir
es que el éxito de los chinos o de los
rusos se nutre de las fallas de los
países occidentales y sobre todo del
egoísmo de los países más ricos en
febrero el director general de la
organización mundial de la salud dijo
que el 60 por ciento de las vacunas
habían estado
que los países más ricos del mundo ya
que representan 16 por ciento de la
población habían comprado 60 y 160 por
ciento de las vacunas entonces hay un
nacionalismo de las vacunas primero de
parte de los países occidentales y eso
llega a lo que vemos ahora de la
capacidad y la posibilidad de los de los
chinos y de los rusos a ofrecer vacunas
a países menos ricos entonces es lugar
el primer punto segundo punto es lo que
lo que ilustra muy bien es la desunión
de la unión europera pero es un problema
vigente desde hace mucho tiempo y además
en un sector de la salud que no es un
problema europeo es uno es un problema
nacional entonces hay que construir y lo
vimos el jueves con el consejo europeo
los romeros tienen que construir esa
estrategia ahora porque la unión europea
acusa al laboratorio astrazéneca de no
cumplir con sus compromisos aunque
probablemente el bloque europeo no
negoció mal a que el contrato que decía
siempre que sus capacidades lo
permitiesen que es el que se agarra
siempre el laboratorio y ahora
descubrimos que en el laboratorio
escondían 29 millones de dosis en italia
se sospecha que para enviarles a reunir
aunque luego astrazéneca ha dicho que no
era para el reino unido que era para ohl
kóvacs bueno todo esto no sé si va a
acabar en una espiral judicial poco
pragmática en estos momentos dijo ayer
el presidente macro que quizá en la
unión europea ha pecado de inocente en
todo en todo este asunto david puede ser
puede ser y parece que en frente de eeuu
que está con política de américa a first
por ejemplo las vacunas de facer en
canadá vienen de plantas que están en
europa hay plantas de facer en el lago
michigan del otro lado de la frontera
pero la frontera está cerrada para
vacunas que están fabricadas en eeuu
también en el reino unido tiene una
política de yucay first y ahora la unión
europea está bajado está bajo presión de
hacer lo mismo debe ser una política de
europa first y
yo creo que no quería hacer eso que
pensaba que
de que una estrategia global
estaba para ponerse en marcha y ahora me
está viendo que no que cada país está
está con una postura muy nacionalista y
está y está ahora por tener una
una política igual de europa a force y
después veamos claros que europa dice
que mientras europa exporta 2 millones
de dosis a mercados extranjeros y esos
otros mercados no han exportado sino que
han ejercido esa especie de
proteccionismo
a partir de ese proteccionismo y ese
egoísmo estos estos países de los que
hablamos hacen sus donaciones en un
momento en el que eeuu y otros países
ricos están acaparando los suministros
mundiales los países más pobres intentan
conseguir los suyos una disparidad que
según advirtió la organización mundial
de la salud recientemente ha llevado al
mundo al borde de un fracaso moral
catastrófico coinciden con esta
apreciación introduciendo introducimos
ahora el elemento moral en toda esta
historia françois sí por supuesto
lo que a mí lo que me llama la atención
es el fracaso de kóvacs en ese sistema
que supuestamente tenía que poner la
vacuna como un bien común mundial y
había así gran disco grandes discursos
sobre la necesidad de compartir de
producir para la luz lo más pobres pero
bueno es es lo que decía antes es un
mercado así con intereses económicos más
fuertes con intereses privados es en ese
en ese terreno como dijo boris johnson
bueno después dijo que bromeaba pero
dijo que el éxito de la vacunación en el
reino unido se basaba en la codicia y el
capitalismo y aquí aquí estamos
es una cuestión de capitalismo de precio
de capacidad de maniobrar de de
conseguir precios de lo vemos con eeuu
porque hay ese éxito en eeuu porque
pusieron esfuerzos pusieron dinero
hubo ese nacionalismo y ese es un éxito
pero matrona habló hace unas horas
también de riesgo de que eeuu ha puesto
más riesgo para innovar para crecer para
crear que la europe que casey cake y que
hay que extraer consecuencias de ello
vamos a volver a moscú porque antes se
refería a françois los dos modelos
distintos entre china y rusia en más que
exportar la vacuna rusia quiere firmar
acuerdos de producción en el extranjero
para poder reservar sus capacidades al
abastecimiento de la población rusa
xavier colás moscú como se articula esa
producción exterior de rusia
para sputnik es muy importante la
producción en el extranjero hay que
recordar que la vacuna sputnik está
creada por un laboratorio ruso es el
centro una malla que no tiene la
infraestructura por ejemplo que
podríamos esperar en el caso de una
farmacéutica mundialmente conocida como
face esto hace que aunque han hecho un
buen trabajo investigando y consiguiendo
una vacuna propia no pueden producirla
no tienen ese músculo de producción que
tienen otras otras vacunas al menos de
momento va a llevar tiempo por eso se ha
puesto muchas esperanzas en algunos
acuerdos en el extranjero y ahí destaca
por ejemplo el caso de india que es la
gran esperanza para poder producir la
vacuna sputnik para otros países que con
los que ya se han comprometido porque
hay que recordar que es poner por
ejemplo está llegando a argentina méxico
y también ha hecho
a importantes acuerdos con otros países
de américa latina para poder cumplir
esos compromisos no se necesita producir
en el extranjero pero obviamente esto no
es cuestión de días porque hace falta
cerrar un acuerdo que se cree la
infraestructura y también hacer una lo
que lo que llaman en el sector la
transferencia de tecnología es decir los
conocimientos que ahora mismo están en
rusia transferirlos para que el
medicamento sea exactamente el mismo la
vacuna que se está produciendo en rusia
desde ese punto de vista es muy fácil
entender porque a moscú le interesa
tanto la luz verde en europa la
autorización de el visto bueno de la ema
en europa porque en la unión europea
siempre va a dar prioridad a vacunas que
se produzcan en suelo europeo por una
cuestión logística así que si rusia
recibe luz verde del además será todavía
más fácil pensar en plantas de
producción en suelo europeo ya hay un
acuerdo firmado con italia y sabemos que
se están negociando por ejemplo
con una empresa en galicia en el norte
de españa
moscú asegura que lleva a cabo
conversaciones con varios países
europeos lo que en realidad estamos
hablando de empresas que quieren
producir la vacuna rusa hacer negocios
su sector por supuesto ganar dinero pero
esto insisto no va a ser algo que ocurra
de la noche a la mañana porque en cada
caso del nuevo productor en cada caso de
contratista también tiene que ser
verificado por la ema esto a corto plazo
parece muy farragoso y muy difícil de
conseguir es verdad que va a haber que
esperar pero sí que puede ser una opción
interesante a medio o largo plazo porque
dentro de un año nos dijese que puede
ser un importante productor de vacunas
es que como nos cuenta xavier a rusia le
interesa
toda la infraestructura ya creada para
rusia europa es un mercado absolutamente
muy atractivo
y más allá de la cuestión económica es
la en cuestión industrial y el poder que
puede representar tener vacunas así y
conseguir ventajas lado ms aseguró que
cada día que pasa la iniquidad para el
acceso a las vacunas contra la comida es
cada vez más notoria david está
desigualdad de acceso quizá es la base
de todo este juego diplomático que
estamos viendo es decir todos este juego
de influencia se crea porque hay una
desigualdad no como indica la ms y que
cada vez además aumenta estamos en una
situación de desigualdad absoluta como
decía 4 por ciento de las vacunas a
nivel mundial han llegado a américa
latina
américa latina no va a tener
perspectivas de vacunación hasta
de tener una gran parte de su población
vacunada del final del año esté claro se
habla de un panorama desigual mundial
pero es que además en particular
latinoamérica es ya de por sí una región
con grandes desigualdades entre los
países es que se va a ver mientras chile
llegue muy pronto a esa inmunización
colectiva otros países estarán empezando
lo que vamos a tener sorpresas también
lo que está pasando en cuba es muy
interesante quizás en algunos meses
vamos a ver a cuba con sus propias sus
vacunas producidas y fabricadas en cuba
con la capacidad de vacunar su población
y de exportar
a los países que ellos erigen
es el plan del gobierno cubano dicen que
antes del final del año van a poder
exportar 100 100 millones de dosis de
vacunas y que balas lo van a hacer con
con una política de distribución para
combatir la igualdad de acceso a las
vacunas hablaremos si lo consiguen pero
se puede se puede dar una clara sorpresa
en términos de desde lo político por
supuesto que no sería posible en toda la
geopolítica que me quedo ya sin tiempo
para más toda la geopolítica que hay
detrás de todo este juego de vacunas en
plena pandemia por cierto dice mucho de
cómo está el mundo muchísimas gracias a
todos y a todos ustedes hasta la semana
que viene aquí en primera plana gracias
[Música]